big changes for the buccaneers this
offseason starting with that
paint-drinking head coach who came out
of retirement for the second time bruce
aaron the first time he retired it
really wasn't a retirement the second
time it was but then it wasn't he's back
in the game after his time with the
cardinals and big cat i look at this as
the key move that that just from an all
or nothing standpoint right 5 and 11
they were last year this is either going
to go great for the buccaneers or it's
going to be a disaster we're going to
find out fairly quickly whether or not
bruce arians can make this thing work
and job number one is get the most out
of their franchise quarterback who has
yet to play consistently like a
franchise quarterback jameis winston
so the bruce arians jameis winston uh
relationship is obviously the headliner
here but to me what the bucks have done
this off season you have todd bowles be
the defensive coordinator and probably
not a good head coach but he's going to
be the guy who will hopefully make this
defense better than i think they were
second to last or last however you want
to look at it i think todd bowles and
their draft if you look at their draft
they went heavy heavy heavy on defense
which is a sign to
everyone that bruce arians thinks he has
enough on offense to make this thing go
with jameis winston with mike evans and
he can figure out a way to get the most
out of him can the defense kind of catch
up to what bruce arians will be doing on
the offensive side of the ball
desean jackson gone he was the deep
threat in the offense prashad param and
they hope that he can
at some level duplicate what desean
jackson did although herman's been a
disappointment most of his career
the the one thing that came up recently
for the buccaneers that's going to be a
problem that jason pierre-paul neck
injury from the one vehicle accident
over the weekend he could miss all of
the season he could miss into the second
month of the season that's going to take
a toll on that pass rush and you're
right the resources committed to the
defensive side of the ball in the draft
they know that's where they need to beef
up because offensively aryans is
confident he can get the most out of
what they have and they've got one of
the more underrated players in all of
football in mike evans so i don't know
that they needed desean jackson mike
evans has been great for them o.j howard
could be coming into his own as one of
the best tight ends in football cameron
breit still continues to be very
effective pass catcher it's all going to
come down to winston though i mean you
know winston has that that genetic
defect where he thinks he can do more
than what he actually can and he all too
often tries to do more than what he's
physically able to do and i think that's
the one thing that ariens needs to
engineer out of winston's dna if he can
if he can that there's a question as to
whether at this point in a guy's career
you can get him to not make that
god-awful attempt at making something
happen at the worst possible moment but
if if aryans is able to do that then he
will be successful
it's the brett favre uh genetic defect
that you're talking about when it's good
you're a gunslinger and everyone loves
it and you're a guy who makes plays when
it's bad you're you are looking really
bad and you know you're right jameis
winston does have that proclivity to
make those key interceptions red zone
interceptions red zone fumbles where i i
feel like when i i always used to make a
joke like the red zone channel when it
when you flip to it when they would go
to the bucs games it was a 50 50 shot it
was a good player jameis winston fumble
because it feels like the ball is kind
of always floating in in the air when
he's there the other thing the other two
pieces that i i noted when i did a
little research for you mike because
yeah i do research for this show uh
the bucks are making the transition to a
3-4 defense so they used to be a 4-3
they're gonna blitz a lot more we talked
about the defensive side of the ball
with todd bowles and then finally i know
this is an off-season acquisition but
you have to when you're talking about
the box in 2019 you have to mention that
brutal brutal stretch that they're gonna
have where they have 18 000 miles
traveled between week four and week nine
and can the team survive that because
they could be great from for the first
three weeks they could look great bruce
arians could be playing great you know
or coaching great football with jameis
winston but when they hit that that that
stretch there it's going to be a bear
they go at rams at saints i think
there's a london game in there yeah the
london game is actually the carolina
game so what you think is a home game in
there is not a home game then they go at
titans all the way across the country of
the seahawks so will the bucks be able
to survive that gauntlet i mean that's
actually looking at it right now it's
actually incredible what the nfl kind of
did to them going west coast to the
saints to england to tennessee all the
way back to the west coast if they can't
survive that the season could be over
very quickly
now and you look at the back end of the
schedule three of the last four games at
home if they are not in playoff
contention that stadium is going to be a
ghost town those last three home games
and that's one of the problems when you
have that seven week gap in the middle
of the season where you don't have a
game in your home stadium if you you get
a lot of games clustered at either the
beginning of the end of the season for
them they get three of the last four at
home it's going to be horrible if
they're not in contention if they are in
contention it's going to be spectacular
we'll see if they can do it the over
under has been set at six and a half
wins for the bucks that's one and a half
more than they had last year where are
you going over or under
i'll probably go under i'm going to hurt
uh my producer stephen chay when i say
because he's the biggest bucks fan i
know but i'm probably going to go under
just because of that schedule i mean
that that stretch is going to be very
very hard to deal with and i am not a
believer in jameis winston i'm a
believer in bruce arians i'm not a
believer in jameis winston you alluded
to it mike when you have that uh you
know like whatever whatever it is inside
of you where you're just throwing the
ball away or you're a little careless
with the ball in key situations i think
it's very very hard to coach out of
someone and i think jameis winston as as
bruce arians will try i think he still
will have a little bit of that trait in
him and that will sink them to maybe a
six-win team instead of an eight-win
team
where do you think winston plays next
year
that's a great question i have no idea
the dolphins i feel like you could just
say the dolphins whenever a quarterback
comes up and you can make you can have
like a 50 50 chance of being right back
up quarterback for your chicago bears
jameis no
getting ready get ready 20 20. all right
we're gonna take a break we're gonna do
some pft props as this friday edition of
pro football talk live on nbc sports
radio and nbcsn continues right after
this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports